a hidden pattern is popping up in
seemingly unrelated places from a bus
system in Mexico to chicken eyes to
number theory in quantum physics this
phenomenon known as universality
continues to surprise mathematicians and
reveal a deeper understanding of our
world imagine arriving at an empty bus
stop in New York City the last bus must
have just left but the sign says a bus
comes every 10 minutes on average what's
the probability that the next bus will
arrive within five minutes the
probability of a random event happening
within some interval like a bus coming
within the next five minutes is given by
a curve called a Poisson distribution
but what if bus arrival times are not
independent in the 1970s in Cuernavaca
Mexico bus drivers would hire spies to
sit along their route and the drivers
either speed up or waited a stop
depending on how long ago their spies
said the previous bus left
this spaced-out the bus's and maximize
their profits in that case the spacing
between buses is defined by a very
different probability distribution the
corn Ibaka bus system the Riemann zeta
function related to prime numbers
chicken retinas and atomic nuclei are
all examples of complex correlated
systems the components of these systems
aren't independent they interact and
repel one another and this leads to a
statistical distribution in between
randomness and order the same
distribution or pattern arises even
though the components of these various
systems are very different they are said
to exhibit universality mathematicians
model these complex correlated systems
using random matrices the numbers and
random matrices are drawn randomly from
probability distributions the matrix
might be randomly filled with zeros and
ones or with any set of numbers like the
integers between 1 and a hundred you can
characterize a matrix by its eigen
values a series of numbers that can be
calculated by multiplying components of
the matrix together in a certain way I
can values of random matrices are always
spaced along a number line in a
characteristic pattern with consecutive
eigen values never too close together or
too far apart the same pattern of eigen
values spacings arises no matter how you
fill the matrix with random numbers if
you plot that as since between
consecutive eigen values on the x axis
in the probability of getting a
particular spacing on the y axis the
familiar lopsided curve begins to appear
researchers are still looking for a
general answer to where this universal
pattern
from but clues continue to emerge the
idea of random matrix universality goes
back to Eugene Wigner a Nobel
prize-winning theoretical physicist who
worked on the Manhattan Project
Wigner was attempting to calculate the
energy levels of a uranium nucleus which
has more than 200 protons and neutrons
that can arrange themselves in all
different configurations the associated
energy levels of the system were far too
complex to calculate Wigner used random
matrices instead and plotted the
statistical distribution of eigenvalues
he found that the spacing of these
numbers matched the spacing of energy
levels of uranium and other heavy atomic
nuclei two decades later the pattern was
seen in gaps between consecutive numbers
called zeros of the Riemann
zeta-function
these zeroes are thought to control how
prime numbers are distributed since then
the pattern has been seen in many
different settings like in human bones
and social networks just recently it
showed up in yet another unlikely place
the eyes of chickens it was the first
instance in the pattern seen in biology
while the number line exhibits a pattern
of universality in one dimension the
chicken retina sounds reveals it in two
dimensions the color sensitive cone
cells on the chicken's retina seem
haphazardly distributed but with a
remarkably uniform density looking
closer the cells appeared to be
surrounded by what's called an exclusion
region a space where cones with
different color sensitivity can be found
the cones of the same kind cannot
just how these cone cells create the
exclusion zones remains a mystery but
it's similar to the repulsion between
consecutive random matrix eigenvalues on
the number line
researchers say we're just at the tip of
the iceberg in understanding
universality in map physics in even
biology
[Music]